EARLY.
WHICH IS MORE LIKELY?
WE WILL LEAVE THAT TO YOU.
>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: NEW YORK UNIVERSITY
WORLD.
AT LEAST ONE PERSON IS
CONTINUING TO REFUSE TO CONFORM.
LIBERAL STUDIES.
MICHAEL, HE IS SUING THE SCHOOL
ACCUSING THEM OF LAUNCHING A
HARASSMENT CAMPAIGN AGAINST HIM.
HE JOINS US NOW.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: TELL US WHAT YOU DID
TO EARN THE IRE OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES?
>> I STARTED AN ANONYMOUS
TWITTER ACCOUNT AND TWEETED
CRITICISMS OF IDEALOGY ON
CAMPUS.
SHUTTING DOWN SPEAKERS AND SO
FORTH.
>> Tucker: WHAT THINGS DID YOU
TWEET?
THREATEN ANYONE WITH VIOLENCE?
>> NO, NOT ALL.
I MADE CRITICISMS ABOUT WHAT WAS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AS THE CAMPUS CRAZINESS
ESCALATED AND YOU HAD RIOTS BY
THE TIME BERKELEY HAPPENED.
I WAS MAKING CRITIQUES OF AN
INSTITUTIONAL ADOPTION AND THE
MECHANISMS TO ENFORCE IT.
I MENTIONED NO GROUPS.
NO IDENTITIES AT ALL.
I WAS IMMEDIATELY WITHIN TWO
DAYS OF AN INTERVIEW APPEARING,
I WAS CALLED INTO THE DEAN'S
OFFICE.
I WAS TOLD THAT THE INTERVIEW
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH MY
YET, IMMEDIATELY IT WENT TO THAT
TOPIC.
I WAS TOLD THAT PEOPLE WERE
[LAUGHING].
>> Tucker: BECAUSE YOU DISAGREED
WITH THEM?
>> I MUST BE CRAZY BECAUSE I
DISAGREED WITH THEM.
I WAS PUT ON PAID LEAVE AND
STRONGLY ENCOURAGED TO TAKE A
PAID OF LEAVE ABSENCE AND LEAVE
CAMPUS IMMEDIATELY.
A COMMITTEE CALLING THEMSELVES
THE DIVERSITY EQUITY AND
INCLUSION GROUP DENOUNCED ME IN
A DOUBLE-SPEAK CONDEMNATION
WHERE THEY SAID I WAS GUILTY FOR
THOUGHTS.
>> Tucker: THE INCLUSION
COMMITTEE EXCLUDED YOU?
>> THAT'S THEY DID.
THAT'S WHY I CALL THEM THE
EXCLUSION GROUP.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHING].
THERE ARE SO MANY QUESTIONS
HERE.
DID ANY COLLEAGUES APPROACH YOU
AND SAY YOU ARE TELLING SOME
TRUTH HERE?
OR COWERED.
IT'S A CHILLING EFFECT ON
CAMPUSES.
CAN'T VOICE DISAGREEMENT WITH
SATAN AS HE WAS CALLED.
>> Tucker: HOW YOU CAN THINK
CLEARLY IF CONFORMITY IS
THIS IS AGAINST THE MISSION OF
THE UNIVERSITY.
THAT'S WHAT I WAS COMPLAINING
WELL.
>> Tucker: IF THESE PEOPLE HAD
POWER, A LOT OF PEOPLE WOULD
NOW?
ASSAILED IN A SERIES OF
BLISTERING EMAILS AND ATTACKED
FOR NOTHING.
I NEVER SPOKE TO ANY OF THESE
PEOPLE BY NAME OR DIRECTLY AT
ALL.
THEY STARTED TO ATTACK ME.
CALLING ME RACIST AND SEXIST AND
SATAN.
SHORT PANTS, FRAGILE WHITE MALE.
I WAS PELTED WITH SEXIST AND
RACIST EPITATHS.
>> Tucker: IT'S ONE THING TO
STAND UP AND TAKE A POSITION
THAT PEOPLE DISAGREE WITH.
TO TAKE A POSITION AGAINST